Ah!
Eliezer?
Yes.
It's so nice to meet you.
Welcome, welcome.
This is beautiful!
Yes!
This is where the
Templars actually hung out?
In here?
No, no, no.
This is not the Templar.
We are in the right place,
but in the wrong time.
Let's go.
If we want to see
the Templar building,
we have to go down
beneath this church.
[music playing]
Here?
This is it?
Yeah.
Under this door, we are
going to see another world.
We [inaudible].
This is like out
of a movie right now.
Are you kidding me?
We're going to go
into a secret door--
Yeah.
--behind a junk shop?
[key turning]
Wow.
Let's go.
What!
Wow!
This is incredible!
Now we are in the right
time, in the right place.
Here we are in the
12th and 13th century.
This is underground,
buried crypt.
This is really where the
Templar was 800 years ago.
So creepy.
I'm standing in a room that
ancient, medieval knights, the
Knights Templar hung out in?
Yes, they lived here
more than 200 years.
I bet they never
thought there'd be
a bionic foot on their floor.
This is the first
floor of the building.
But in the 13th century, the
crusader church was above us.
So we were just standing,
a few moments ago, in
another church right above me?
Mm-hmm.
So there's church upon church?
Yeah.
It's kind of crazy because
when you stand down here,
it doesn't look all that
different from the church
upstairs in terms of style.
Because you have the arches--
The arches and
everything, yes.
But if you are
looking carefully,
the Templar masonry
work, it's completely
another architecture.
Wow.
The stones are much bigger
than the 19th century building.
Look at that.
It's very famous in
the crusader period
that a lot of stones
has the masonry marks.
Whoa.
So you see you this line--
Or maybe here, this one.
Oh, yes, exactly this one.
So this is actually the
mark of somebody's chisel?
Mm-hmm, form of the Templar.
Ah, this is so cool!
When you find something that
you can connect to the people
that actually built
this building,
this is what's so
exciting for me.
Because you actually
get to the person?
Yes, exactly.
[music playing]
ALBERT LIN (VOICEOVER):
Further below the modern city,
about 10 feet beneath the
crypt, are more vaults.
The secret chambers, a
medieval knights' crypt.
Nuts.
ALBERT LIN (VOICEOVER):
We've established
that this was a
Templar building,
but I don't know
what it was used for.
Wow!
(QUIETLY) Wow.
This is carved out
of the earth, huh?
(ECHOING) Hello!
What is this?
This is for
collecting rainwater.
It's a huge,
underground water tank.
You can actually
see the little channel
where the water pours in
from the rain, right there.
The Holy Land is
very, very warm.
We are in the Middle East
and you need the water.
ALBERT LIN (VOICEOVER):
Eliezer has
excavated three of these
25,000 gallon tanks so far.
And he believes
there are many more.